hey we're back again with another movie
review this one is kind of a
controversial oh man it's like a
childhood classic of mine dude yes I
read the book and then I saw the movie
alright and I loved the movie has a kid
even though probably I probably wouldn't
have understood it had I not read the
book yeah that's that's a very common
complaint dune dune is not a movie or
Bowl story yeah hard to make this into a
movie it's kind of like the equivalent
of trying to take the book of Genesis
and making that like an hour and a half
long movie right where you're trying to
get you know the Garden of Eden story
the flood story you know stories of
Abraham and eight and then Abraham and
Isaac and then you're gonna try to do
you know the story of Joseph you know
try to do all that in one movie you just
can't do it I always kind of felt like I
mean I read the book probably I don't
even really remember that much about it
cuz I probably read it when I was maybe
12 or 13 years old which was a very long
time ago even then I don't know it seems
to me that yes the book is very dense
and there's like a lot of [ __ ] going on
but I feel like you could make it into
not a movie necessarily I think it needs
a series because it needs like a lot
more room to breathe or if you were
gonna do movies and it would at least
have to be a trilogy I would think I
think you can make this into a trilogy
yeah war style trailer that might work
which you know when they made the movie
it was supposed to be some competition
for Star Wars so I don't know why you
know it's a way you know Dino did that
kind of [ __ ] he you know anything he
touched basically turned to [ __ ] turned
to gold or it turned to [ __ ] one of the
two of course you know because there was
some really good [ __ ] that he did what
Conan won yeah Flash Gordon just a son
when when when that company screwed up
it screwed up badly dune got a lot of
things right but it also one of those
got a lot of things wrong and one of the
things that really got wrong is they try
to mash that entire story into one movie
to compete with Star Wars if you're
gonna be compete with Star
make a trilogy like Star Wars was gonna
yeah it's not like it was unheard of it
no I'm it just seems like and the thing
about doing it it had such a you know
complicated history like it had been
optioned like many times by many
different directors famously Alejandro
Jodorowsky was going to do it which
actually I would have loved to saying
that cuz that guy makes weird [ __ ] yeah
he said it was gonna be an acid trip
yeah but yeah which most of his other
movies are yeah it was gonna have whole
what's his name minute Marlon Brando was
gonna play a role in a fat Marlon Brando
not not skinny Marlon Brando so that's a
bit a trip Alvin or dolly is supposed to
be absolutely like that that actually
might have been kind of RAD I don't know
who Brando would have played maybe blat
Baron Vladimir Harkonnen yeah that seems
like something yeah maybe we should back
up and give people kind of a little more
information about dune and what it is
because maybe some people haven't seen
it I recommend the movie in the original
cut and the theatrical cut if you want
to take it as it's a masterpiece shitty
movie it's the best of the bad movies
I've seen it looks good it feels good it
doesn't make any sense if you don't know
what's going on right I've seen it
called things like a beautiful disaster
that kind of thing which seems to me a
good cuz it looks I mean other than a
couple of ropey special effects it
actually still looks fantastic like the
set design is beautiful and the
costuming is beautiful and all the
actors in it are good yeah it's just
every you hadn't read the book even if
you had read the book you will have no
[ __ ] idea what the [ __ ] is going on
you have to see it a bunch of times to
kind of get an idea of yeah it's going
on it's definitely something that needs
repeat feeling yeah and I don't think
you would really get the depth of what
was going on had you know just on the
movie alone because I think a lot of the
stuff that I got from watching the movie
because I knew what it was talking about
cuz I read the book I don't know if I'm
person who had not read the book with
you yeah I mean you gotta think like the
original book kind of [ __ ] glossary
you guys yeah
so you know what I mean but I don't
think that that is necessarily a
detriment because you know good a good
trilogy was made out of Lord of the
Rings
you know they've made like these big
epic sprawling movies or trilogies or
series or whatever out of really
complicated dense
Tyrael where there's like a lot of care
to look at like Game of Thrones and
stuff like that where there's all these
different characters and all these in
our connecting storylines
it can be done yeah there's a [ __ ] ton
of characters there's a [ __ ] ton of fun
the historical background most of most
of the book is narrated yeah there's
very little conversational dialogue in
this so right
very hard to make a movie out of that
and I could look but ya can't the
harlots a classic book I mean you know
it's it's pretty much you know an
acknowledged sci-fi it's like reading
the Old Testament just in and it's even
in another language basically there's
kind of a pseudo language that Frank
Poupart has made up right to describe
technologies and political systems that
don't exist yet because this is
thousands of years in the future and you
know let me say toons that I mean anyone
that listens to the show or anything is
probably you probably know what I'm sure
I've mentioned it before David Lynch is
probably I mean probably my favorite
movie director um I love pretty much
every movie he's done yeah except this
one I don't hate it
I don't love it this one it just seems
well even David Lynch himself has kind
of distanced himself from it a little
bit and on some cuts of the movie he
actually used the Alan Smithee you know
pseudonym that directors use and he also
used a pseudonym for the screenwriting
credit he he called himself Judas booth
I think Mintz for me is too hard to
watch I don't mind general don't like
most of his movies all right I do like
this one yeah that's really fun
backwards
well yeah it's it's funny because I
think a lot of people complain about
David Lynch's MO oh you know they don't
make any sense or anything which they
actually they do they're just very
symbolic or they use like dreamlike
logic and things like that
you usually have to see them several
times and also he he makes reference to
a lot of other films too like in it you
know cuz like I said I wanted to do
Mulholland Drive on this series at some
point to where he makes like a lot of
references to Sunset Boulevard and then
there was wild at heart where he made a
bunch of references to Wizard of Oz and
you know things like that so you kind of
have to have like a you know a knowledge
of a lot of other film a lot of other
films and a lot of
other things too you know understand the
symbolism and stuff that he's doing and
at this point when he made dune I'm
pretty sure I think at this point he had
only made he had made Eraserhead
obviously he had made the elephant man
oh that was a good one yeah and and I
think that's and I think those are like
the only the two major films he had made
he hadn't made blue velvet yet he had
made because this was Kyle MacLachlan
who plays Paul Atreides in dune this was
actually his first movie yeah just a
good job and Kyle MacLachlan would
obviously go on to work with David Lynch
a lot more he was in blue but blue
velvet obviously and he would play Agent
Dale Cooper on Twin Peaks in 1990 and in
the new one also and there are also
there are a ton of other actors in this
movie that David Lynch worked with again
and again he had like a stable of actors
that he liked to use but I think the
main mistake and I don't know if this
was necessarily his decision I mean
David Lynch did write the screenplay
his original screenplay I think was a
movie about four hours long take you
know because like I said it's a very
dense book it took him like six months
to write it and I kind of feel like me
and and maybe he was kind of pushed into
this decision but I don't like that so
much of the movie is conveyed in
people's like voiceovers like they're
thinking like they're thinking about it
it's kind of the way the book was they
should have done that but yeah that's
the thing and I think and I don't know
if I've mentioned this on the show
before but you know there's kind of a
big difference about what works in a
book and what works in a movie and if
there's a book where it just has it's
mostly people's internal monologues and
things like that which like a lot of
Stephen King books are like that where a
lot of it's just inside a person's head
but in a movie that tends not to work
very well it comes across as very cheesy
very forced and contrived and I kind of
wish he had found another way yeah
to get a lot of the information across
but on the other hand it doesn't it
doesn't work that well okay but it does
give this weird air of it of
self-importance this movies taking
itself very oh yeah seriously oh yeah
almost cattle
here it's the Old Testament that's what
it is it does come across that was a
science fiction
Old Testament everything that's being
said is some kind of a meme some kind of
religious it's a pronouncement that
religious pronouncement from a holy book
that's what everything's yeah no one no
one can just like talk like regular all
like everything has to be this big like
ostentatious yeah it's why you're
basically seeing space kabuki yeah no
it's like space yeah but but but Middle
Eastern this is this is this is you know
Old Testament stuff and it's definitely
bunch of refer a references to a
futuristic versions of Christianity
Judaism and Islam they're referring to
that a lot a lot of the the stuff that
the Fremen the things that they are
saying they're takeoffs of Arabic terms
yeah like instead of fitting they use
the word fit Akeem you know the that's
just one of the guys I've heard they
also use the word jihad the spice that
they're mining is oil yes I was gonna
say and yeah that's kind of the whole
book has been bred as a as a metaphor
for Middle Eastern Bombay is Middle
Eastern politics and you know their
command over the oil production and
around the world and stuff like that and
like I said on the surface it doesn't
seem like it's a complicated story but
not unnecessarily
um one that people wouldn't be able to
understand I mean it's just you know
there's a planet called Arrakis
otherwise known as dune and that's where
the spice is it's called melange and
they use the spice to fold space they
usually spice it's kind of like a drug
it's a drug yeah Haila and you can see
slightly into the future yeah it gives
you like psychic powers and stuff like
that yeah so and basically it's several
ruling families from different planets
that are fighting over a command over
control of the spite of this planet and
then there's also the Fremen who are the
native people of Arrakis and they're
kind of in the mix too and they have a
thing about a messiah and Paul Atreides
is supposed
Masaya and all this other kind of stuff
so like I said it's not if you just read
a plot synopsis it seems like it should
be a glance like it seems like you could
make it make sense right but then when
you watch the movie it somehow does not
make sense yeah and here's the thing I
bought a like a collector's edition DVD
this was like from it's not even blu-ray
but this was from a few years back and
it came with two different versions of
the movie the theatrical release and an
extended cut that most of the critics or
the or the do fanatics like this
particular that was the one that was on
TV right that they had and no no that
one he had even more in it yeah cause
the one on TV was like they added like
45 because I'm generally a fan of the
theatrical cut I said I you know I bet
you there's more extended cut is even
better I was wrong
more is not better in terms of doing
more actually makes it worse more of the
movie the way it's cut and the way it's
edited in more information seems to or
excuse me what's a good way to put it
the additional scenes confuse the hell
out of you unless you don't know exactly
what's going on and they're not really
netis necessary after having watched the
extended cut I prefer the theatrical cut
better but yeah imperfect and I'm
actually thinking about going back and
getting the blue the new blu-ray edition
because it's dirt cheap
oh yeah eBay I think it's like four or
five bucks or something yeah birds you
know and evidently the the the image
quality the sound quality is a lot
better and it's just a regular cut now
the version I saw like we watched what
was the version that we watched the
theatrical version or we watch the
extended we watch the extended edition
it's just [ __ ] because yes okay now
the theatrical version had the opening
with virginia madsen right that's right
kind of like who just gave like a little
like few minutes and that actually kind
of is a classy intro yeah I like how
that worked but the extended version it
kind of has this sort of sloppily put
together that cartoons
it's like 12 or 13 minutes long right
they're feeling that they have to
explain the entire past 5,000 years of
his right so you know what
there was the extended cut is cool for a
guy who really has to know more about
the movie I like that that that concept
but on a first viewing I wouldn't
recommend the extend cut and for people
who don't know what the Dune universe is
all about it's one of the cool things
about it is that it's futuristic but
there is no real technology as you would
know it because they explained early on
that thousands of years ago you know
before their telling of this story
AI got so good that artificial
intelligent robots started to take over
and humans had to make this big a
prizing kind of Skynet [ __ ] kind of like
Skynet this is that the robots really
were like pretty overprotective mothers
they wouldn't let you do anything so the
people atrophied immensely they had a
revolt they got rid of AI they rewrote
the Bible and holy books and ingrained
people with like a new religion that and
one of the commandments was is that
shalt not make a machine in the form of
the mind of a man so in other words no
AI no computers and then instead of
computers they opened up all these
schools to further human development so
people they would try to turn people
into astounding thinkers and athletes
and basically you know call most kind of
like Scientology level ot power ot is
operating thetan power you know magic
could not really but you know psychic
abilities you know they had all that and
so the humans had unlocked their
potential and in many ways but they who
did not allow for computers all right
now when they did this they also opened
up some other weird things like you
could take a person a dead person they
believe it was this was ethical you
could take a dead person reanimate it
give it a bunch of drugs send it to
school and turn it into something called
a mint at which was kind of like a
zombie but they were just mental
gymnasts and you could buy and sell one
like a home computer but only really
rich
people could afford him and there are
many men tears several men tats in the
story and they were doing weird things
like drinking this juice a set foo which
was is a long story okay it's just it's
a blue liquid that comes out of worms or
you put a put water in a worm a sand
worm from Arrakis and it vomits up this
blue liquid you drink it and your
thoughts require your thoughts acquire
speed you know I'm innocent I said to
think real fast really lots of drugs in
this but yeah and even though it's in
the future that doesn't mean I kind of
like this aspect of it just because it's
in the future people haven't really
politically developed that that much
yeah
it's still a monarchy things like
democracies and all that [ __ ] didn't fly
it's just ruling families yeah called
the Lance rod yeah there is an emperor
that oversees him but he's kind of a
puppet it's like futuristic medieval ISM
yeah the Emperor in a way is a puppet
his power is based in space travel
that's what holds the empire together
and for space travel to happen they have
to have spice alright and this spicy
only comes from one planet called dune
and it's basically the [ __ ] these
gigantic words now the transportation
guild that does all the space travel
needs that stuff they inhale it and it
allows them to see slightly in the
future and when they can see slightly in
the future it allows them to kind of
plot a course through dimensions and
allows them to fold space they don't
actually travel they just jump around or
they jump around space almost like some
poltergeist type stuff that you see from
you know in poltergeist some type cases
where there's a sport ation and a
portation that's basically what they're
doing but but it's it's quite cool
actually the concepts are very cool they
didn't solve any of their problems
really with technology per se
yeah they had some technology but it
wasn't computer-based and like I said I
think that's why the book is you know
rightly considered a classic it's a
really cool concept yeah and like I said
I probably I don't think that there's
anything that's unfilmable
I know people have said that about
certain books and stuff like that I know
some things be very difficult and maybe
you'd have to change a lot of things but
like I said I
don't think that it's anymore you know I
I just feel like as something good can
be made of it but maybe not a movie like
it would have to be like I said a
trilogy or a series or something like
that because like I said the concepts
are not hard to understand whoever what
Hubert was free Qbert was an ecologist
really I think that's what his real
training was and he was good at making a
world yeah I read a lot of his books
like Lazarus effect you know I was a kid
he made he made good science fiction but
it's not not all of it was movie about
some of the stuff happened with inside
of a spaceship then yeah I into
thousands of years and mostly most of
the book was him describing a world or a
situation you know in terms of ecology
right how it worked and that's really
what dune that's what dune was really
about it was this interstellar
civilization that was a monarchy held
together by something so simple as like
the [ __ ] of these alien worms when
without that they couldn't they couldn't
travel space and that's what they needed
to hold the empire together
yeah and that was the you know that was
kind of the downfall of this Empire in
the end when you go through the book
yeah and you know it's like a really
cool line out of out of the movie it's
he who controls the spice controls the
universe every single line of dialogue
in this movie is a meme and I've heard
it used in like 10 techno industrial
music from clubs and stuff Beverly yeah
because everything is so grandiose and
big it's a space kabuki it lends itself
well to that well yeah like I said
everything is like a huge grand
pronouncement it's funny as reviled as
this film is it still seems like it has
a big cult following it's cool it's cool
flip I mean and it maybe has a cult
following because because of that so
revised weird yeah it's weird it's like
I don't know I don't know if I'd call it
a bad movie in the way that like you
know Birdemic is a bad yeah no way yeah
it's like I said it's it's just a
confusing movie yeah and I you said
something earlier that I think I did I
agree with I feel like the movie should
have you know because we were talking
about the whole the little part at the
beginning where they you know had this
all this book and
like in the beginning where they had
explained everything I think that the
movie would actually work better and
maybe this is counterintuitive
I think it would work better if it was
less was explained yeah if you knew less
and just allow people to marvel over
what was happening yeah so I think to
anytime I see that kind of thing in a
movie where there's this huge exposition
dump and stuff like that I always feel
like whoever made the movie is not
trusting their audience like they think
that their audiences idiots they have to
explain everything with some of them or
they're afraid that people are not gonna
understand it it's like you know just
hang it out there that you see you just
let things happen and the people will
figure it was stuck in a certain
situation I think if you were to take
dune and try to dumb it down into a
space opera event adventure kind of like
Star Wars it wouldn't have a lot of
adventure action in it because there
isn't a lot of action in the right book
so which would mean that you'd have to
focus on some of the battles that
happened yeah and some of the individual
fights the problem is is in the book the
battles aren't clearly described right
most part you know so there wouldn't be
much dune in the movie it would just be
kind of an action movie and you know
made up by uh what all the cats are in
here yelling okay
get out were worse I yeah there's not a
lot of action in the movie so you can't
really turn it at the level of like a
Star Wars movie yeah that most of the
movie was political intrigue like that
which a good movie could be made from
that yeah yeah but you can't pack all of
that into one movie it has to be a
trilogy I kinda feel like now okay was
there am I remembering it wrong in my
high wasn't there like a TV mini says
yeah it sucked and what she was closer
to the book though right closer to the
book I vaguely recall acting and the
costumes and the look of it were just
the worst for free dick ulis yeah and
that was one thing that that this dune
got right the look and the feel of the
movie is fantastic it is a gorgeous
looking movie that's what
Hubert was talking about yeah in the
book you know I mean the the you know
the the uniforms the outfits the way the
inside the castles looked the way the
inside of spaceships looked I mean just
you know it looked right yeah it looked
and felt right yeah yeah I think that is
definitely the movies the best thing
about the movie is how it looks and like
I said all the actors are good yeah I
mean it's magic [ __ ] Stewart isn't it
yeah and it spawned one of the best
video games of all times dune Emperor he
loves this baby love it it's an old
video game it's kind of like command and
conquer I think the name of the newer
version of it yeah and it's all done in
the dune motif and it's just you know
you know when you used to play that all
the time like he used to play it so much
that I used to hear the little sounds so
he's one reporting reporting like in my
sleep it kind of reminded me of have you
ever played that video if this is
showing my age but have you ever played
that video game called populous yeah
where you get exaggerated but I know
kind of remind it's like that it's good
yeah it's like a you're kind of taking a
bird's-eye view
yeah of the battlefield and you can move
[ __ ] yeah it's about you know going out
and going ascending your harvesters out
to the field to mine spice to bring it
back to build spice refineries and then
you know things that make tanks and
machines and barracks and make an
economy to produce an army to fight
another it's pretty old yeah it's yeah
it's I can't even play it on new windows
yeah that's right and another thing I
should mention too is that this always
kind of made me laugh because I remember
when this movie came out which was 84
right it came out at 84 I remember a lot
of the commercials for it and a lot of
the posters and stuff like that had
[ __ ] sting on there yeah and I was
kind of like you know I was really into
the police at the time and I was like Oh
stings in it maybe I should see it and
stuff like that sting is in it for like
two minutes
yeah instinct an act if you see
brimstone and treacle oh we definitely
have you
- I love [ __ ] Brittany trickle he can
act and he does play an important role
in this movie a role that's never really
shown and he doesn't really do anything
until the very end in the book fade
Ralph the dead stuff yeah he had a
character but in the movie fade Ralph is
hardly in it he's hardly in it and
really really he's is one of the coolest
sting look it is one of one of the
coolest appearances of sting in the
movies his outfit and everything yeah he
looks good that one I was watching
another review like - it was two British
guys and they were watching dune and
they just like could not stop laughing
it stings wing it Underpants the weird
thing about the HAR Conan's were kind of
like I I think they were supposed to be
a an analogy for the Russians I think
it's hard to tell maybe they were an
analogy for the Americans but they were
kind of Baron Vladimir Harkonnen was
kind of like this an aggressive warrior
or homosexual leather daddy
basically yeah and he had like some
things going on with his nephews they
were a very decadent real decadent they
were into kind of like snuff porn and
like yeah in the book one of a drought
those punishments is that he had to
because his his uncle didn't like the
fact that fadeth was into girls he
screwed up one time so he sends fade to
his personal brothel to fade kill all
the females in your personal brothels as
punishment so that's what he had to do
and it was it was like a hundred of them
that's harsh so he went down there with
a knife and killed about a hundred of
them with a you know in his personal
brothel
they had stables of people that they
would give - I do yeah they've been to
other people as rewards and stuff but
that was just the heart Conan have a
girl yes present the heart Conan the
heart Conan economy had a lot of slave
labor in it yeah yeah that was that was
legal for them weird so if you were
going to make let's let's say that I
feel like Netflix should fund a series
yeah of this yeah I feel like if if they
got the right writers and the
I think it could I mean if it had the
same kind of look it has to looking such
as the David Lynch because I think the
look of that was really good it has to
have be kind of dark it has to have that
looking technology it has to have that
feel to it if you did it that way it
would probably work the problem is is
that dune has been botched so many times
consumer confidence would be at an
all-time low that you know way though
that might work in its favor because
really people would be expecting much
yeah and then if you tuned in and it was
like really brilliant yeah they'd never
be like holy [ __ ] [ __ ] and it would
have to take its time and they would
have to invent a bunch of dialogue
because the dialogue isn't there in the
book yeah and no voiceovers very little
dialogue in the book so you have to
invent a bunch of stuff yeah and from
whose point of view do you tell it do
you have to tell it from Paul's point of
view do you change the point of view
because in the book the story to be told
from Paul's point of view and also fade
route this point of view well you would
multiple viewpoints yes in a series I
think they do that in a lot of shows
yeah at least from on if that was from
memory I may be wrong I read that you
like now but I remember that fade route
I think also things were told from his
point of view because they were kind of
like they were direct competitors they
were about the same age in the book
right they were like the then which they
did upcoming generally on that in the
movies enough that those two were kind
of counterparts yeah and they were both
replacing their fathers right okay or
well not so much fate wasn't replacing
his father he was he was replacing his
uncle but same kind deal because like I
said I feel like because you know
Netflix and Showtime and HBO and stuff
like that have kind of shown that
they're willing to do these complicated
like complex yeah series with all these
like intertwining characters and
storylines and all this other kind of
stuff I feel like that would be a good
thing for a reboot especially because
it's never been done well if you did it
you'd have to do it kind of like the
Walking Dead is done
you don't real slowly yeah okay and it's
a bunch of like side missions you know
that's that's what I'm imagining and it
doesn't end until years from now seasons
seasons in season so the first couple
seasons yeah because there's so much
material yeah you could work with the
first couple seasons Paul Atreides would
still have to be on Caledon yeah gross
for several seasons you know getting
ready to you know and then the stuff
happening with the Emperor and Duke Leto
and getting you know which the people
you know I feel like I'm kind of
stepping into deep water because a lot
of the audience pride doesn't know who
it is I'm talking about although maybe
maybe I do they don't know Duke Leto is
balls dad you can see if you see the
theatrical cut you can kind of get an
get an idea of what the movie is about
and if you have questions online there's
a lot of people that talk about it they
can answer it yeah there's tons of
reviews and stuff yeah pretty much all
of them negative I think the only one I
saw that was it was more even-handed was
Oliver Harper's like Oliver Harper's
movie right yeah at respect he actually
um you know he said yeah it was kind of
a mess and stuff like that like you know
it was the story was kind of jumbled but
he actually did enjoy the movie and he
does I have it
yeah don't for one second think this is
a Roger Corman flick it's not a flick
it's a film yeah you know you know it's
it's really expensive you can tell that
they spent a lot of money on this that
they did and the acting is very good it
was not a cheap movie it's just that
it's it's not movable in that stress
confusing very confusing yeah I mean I
really think that that was its downfall
it was one it takes itself a little bit
too seriously maybe and too it's just
they needed to if they were going to
make it one movie which i think is a bad
decision to start with but if you have
to then streamline it you know what I
mean you'd have to streamline it because
you just can't cram all of that into one
movie no no I could understand the
problems that they were in you know I
mean they're telling the director to put
that whole story into a movie well and
try to get it all the whole experience
was actually that was what soured David
Lynch on doing big-budget movies it's
and this was interesting bit of trivia
and I actually didn't know this but
David Lynch was offered this movie he
was also
furred Return of the Jedi Wow which I
would [ __ ] love can I go to an
alternate universe where David Lynch
made return to the Jedi I gotta see that
[ __ ]
yeah so he took this one and he now says
in interviews he doesn't really like to
talk about doom because he really didn't
like how it turned out he said you know
even from the beginning they said well
you're not gonna be able to get final
cut so you're not gonna be able to do
what you want to do dig this it and he's
like so I should have said no but you
know whatever I ended up doing it and
then he later he took his name off of it
and doesn't talk about it and after that
he went his own way he just made his own
movies it's like now he's soured him
forever yeah he's just like I just don't
want to do that anymore cuz David Lynch
he's very good idiosyncratic filmmaker
his [ __ ] is not for everybody and I feel
like he does not work well under
constraints yeah well you know they're
gonna give you that story and say
execute that story in an hour and a half
and he wrote the screenplay off yeah so
although you know it had had they said
look here's the story we're gonna give
you three hours this is gonna be a
three-hour movie or maybe two and a half
hour movie the movie would have it ended
up being a lot better cuz I think two
and a half hours is probably enough to
tell that story like I said it's not my
version that I bought really was not
made from a movie that was intended to
be two and a half hours long that was it
was just little it was made up of those
little trimmings and snippets that were
thrown away to try to get that thing
down to a certain size it's just insane
well in like I said it's not like it was
unheard of for movies TV I mean look at
[ __ ] Ben Hur wasn't that like
three-and-a-half hours longer yeah they
had to do something about the water on
it like a biblical epic one of the
things that David Lynch did which was he
had to get away from the book is that he
had to invent a scene which covered
three or four different storylines to
save time yeah and it had to do with
Paul taking the water of life the one
where he takes the water of life in the
sand words come up in there
like paying homage to him that seemed
kind of tied in a bunch of things and
saved him about about a half hour I may
do that later in the rewrites because I
he did several several yeah ends of the
script right because they had to I mean
the feel like I said the first version
he wrote was like super long and they
were like yeah no you're not doing that
yeah but in a way it's like I don't know
I find it hard to sit through yeah you
know what I mean it's just it's hard for
us just because the last time you sat
through it we were watching that
extended cut yeah the theatrical cut is
not as hard to watch that's true
I love the theatrical cut but I grew up
with watch and see in that movie yeah so
I just accept it for its faults see I
don't it's kind of like kind of like
watching a Bible story for me you know I
mean it is kind of like that that feels
it has that feel to it and I just take
it for what it is I don't think I ever
saw the theatrical cut until recently
because I always saw the TV version yeah
the TV version of done was had some cool
scenes in it but they say that was also
a mess well and I don't think I ever
liked just I don't think I ever just sat
there and watched it like on TV like I
would watch it for like an hour and then
I'd wander off it probably wasn't that
bad when it was interrupted by
commercials cuz you didn't realize how
choppy that would feel
yeah that's jumped around a lot because
even when I was free watching it like I
remembered some scenes but I didn't
really remember yeah the guys I don't
remember ever sitting in one scene I
remember from the TV cut I've never seen
it again but I watched it on television
and that was where the forgot his name
[ __ ] what's his name he was the heart
Conan meant at with the crazy eyes yeah
yeah I saw him he killed us and Brad
Dourif right
I think the actor yeah he killed a
sandworm by putting it in water so he
could get the juice of Sapho out of it
and I never you know and I can remember
that that that worm was I think it was
him that killed it's been a long times
I've seen it and he killed that sand
worm to get the water out of it it was
weird
yeah it's a weird flick I still
recommend it if you've never seen it
check out the theatrical version of it
it's an interest light it helps to read
the book for it helps to read the book
but just sit at least read like a plot
synopsis yeah on Wikipedia if you don't
have time to read the book because
kind of it's kind of a long I would just
kind of just say the movies a trip check
it out it is kind of hits a true
yeah maybe drops of acid I watch the
sleeper must awaken these like
one-liners sitting there that just you
know I feel like it needs like yep yeah
and didn't have kind of a prog-rock you
kind of soundtrack too wasn't it was
Brian you know I think Brian Eno and
Toto and Toto yeah you can't really tell
actually I like that yeah the music
sounds good yeah yeah it's cool it's
very epic the movie was almost a hit had
it been done right you don't mean like
it had the makings of a really good like
you said I think if they had taken a lot
of it out no it would have fought the
story would have fallen apart I hadn't
explained to me by yeah that worked on
the movie in that one documentary and I
see what they're what they're talking
about
yeah they had to to get the story to
work they had that first of all make the
water of life seen and without that
things kind of fall apart you if you
took things away from it it had a bare
minimum C amount of scenes to make sense
yeah if you take anything away then it
doesn't make any sense at all that it's
uh I think they did as well as good as
they could the problem was the time
constraints I've said it over and over
again yeah two and a half hours or three
hours they could have told the story
better or a trilogy
yeah that'd have been the way to do it
do it a trilogy I think that would have
been a better okay that'll do it for our
review of the critically reviled dune
yeah it could have critically revised
weight and legendary dude it's like
samurai kabuki and spaceman Old
Testament styles and Jews and Christians
running around in it you'll see except
not called that they're like what they
evolved into thousands of years from now
alright so if you enjoyed the show
please remember to support us on patreon
or go to our blog which is 13 o'clock
podcast at WordPress comp and give a
one-time donation if you would like to
do that there's a little link in the
sidebar so remember to tune in for our
regular show on Tuesday and we will see
you next time bye